Let's learn another quick piece of syntax that is pretty handy, that I'll
use a lot in this course. And it's just for doing a for
loop. So, the syntax is very much like that of the if statement.
In fact we use, false statements are like this, so, it's going to look like
this. Curly brace and then we'll have our for statement, percent, close curly
brace. And then we can have our, our the body of the for
statement. And just like the if statement, we have a closing block as
well. And our for statement will be just like the Python for statement, and
this, is, allows us to execute or print or whatever, whatever
is in body, do that, you know, in a loop, which is
really handy in a template. So let's go ahead and see a
quick example of that. Okay. We're going to leave our n the way
it is. Okay. And let's replace our if statement demo with a
little for statement demo. So, I'm going to put all of this in
an ordered list. Now, we used unordered list before. Remember ul, ol
is this ordered list, which means I'll actually print the item number.
It's kind of handy. So, for x in range 1 to n plus 1, so this'll basically if n
is 10, this'll go from 1 to 10. And say put a list item, for x
to the power of 2, x squared, which
is Python syntax for doing that. Now notice inside
the, the double curly braces, remember, this just means
print. So, and we can put. Just about any
arbitrary Python inside here, which is indeed what I've done,
so x to the power of 2. And then we
end our for statement, and we close our list. So
let's go ahead and see if this works. I'm going to set
n to 10, and indeed, it works. And we can
see, this basically is printing x, 1 through 10, along, in
the left column, and then x squared in the right
column. let's go ahead and view the source for this file.
You can see down here, here is the code we generated.
Ordered list, and then 1, 4, 9, you know, 1 squared, 2
squared, 3 squared, 4 squared, all the way down to 10
squared, and then close ordered list. And so the template made it
real handy to do that. let's go ahead and see what
would happen if I changed this ordered list to an unordered list
in our code. So if we change this ol to a
ul, and we go back to Chrome and we reload this page,
you see the o changed to u. And we go here, instead of the numbers for
our list items, we get the little dots. It comes up from time to time, these
days you often just generate your list markers
yourself using templates but. You know, for quick
and dirty, you can just use ol or ul to get, to get what you want.